the first woman and the first person of
color to direct a Star Wars film and set
to be released in 2026 you can say that
the force is strong with this one
another win was the
reaction uh by the fans to this new
director of the Star Wars film so uh yes
Star Wars has handed its 67 billion
Empire whatever is left of its Empire uh
to a feminist take a look so the first
woman and the first person of color to
direct a Star Wars film it's set to be
released in 2026 you can say that the
force is strong with this one here's
charmino B
Choi you know I'm very thrilled about
the project because I think um what we
are about to create is something very
special and we're in 2024 now and I
think uh it's about time that we had a
woman uh come forward uh to shape the
story in a galaxy far far
away okay first off everyone's heard me
on this Kathleen Kennedy has been
running Star Wars for the last 10 years
she is a woman she has basically
completely destroyed it uh Colin I think
you're a big Star Wars guy as well uh I
suspect you are not thrilled that they
have handed this to a woman who thinks
that in and of itself being a woman is a
reason to direct Star
Wars I mean it's all the same stuff with
the identitarianism you know so they're
just injecting the activism directly
into the films and this is the problem
with a lot of the woke ID logs they
can't just make movies that embody their
Vision they have to make the movie
overtly about the activism itself and it
always ends up being cringe you know if
you want to challenge Norms just write
your strong female characters this has
been done in ways that doesn't Center
activism gournia Weaver an alien
Jennifer Lawrence Hunger Games uh I even
usually bring up like things like
Bridesmaids which I thought it was a
hilarious movie with an all female cast
cuz they wrote Good characters and funny
but then you have another movie female
Ghostbusters which had almost the exact
same cast and it was terrible because it
it was overtly shoving activism down our
throats so the last thing that the Star
Wars needs is to continue down this
activist path just write the good
characters and the good stories so I
mean hopefully once they see the numbers
of the box office we'll change course
but it might take a few more for them to
really get the
picture